the gang is hitting up platform nine and
three quarters because there's a class
reunion at their alma mater potterheads
here's a new sneak peek of the upcoming
hbo max special harry potter 20th
anniversary return to hogwarts it feels
kind of emotional actually aren't we all
miss granger daniel radcliffe emma
watson and rupert grint are seen
chatting in the first look two decades
after the first movie hit theaters i
thought physically we've all sort of
changed a lot and just as the streaming
service put the friends cast in a
familiar setting looks like these three
are hanging out in the gryffindor common
room ah if those walls could talk oh
wait this is hogwarts
the new image follows this week's new
teaser of the big event
[Music]
the special is also set to feature other
cameos from the potterverse i would
certainly be going yeah including tom
felton helena bonham carter gary oldman
plus he who must not be named himself
they're all voldemort fans i wasn't
expecting that before we get the
retrospective special which debuts
january 1st on hbo max here's something
fun to hold the fans over
that's like one of the craziest sets we
had that's great while chatting with et
this year radcliffe recalled a harry
potter stunt where the danger was a
little too real is there one scene
that's your favorite and or one scene
you would go back and redo if you could
they let me do
the coolest stunt i've ever been able to
do was a a 40 foot full down a roof um i
would i was on a wire but it was i was
like properly in free fall it was only
there to catch me at the end um and i
was absolutely terrified but they they
were like i worked a lot with the stunt
department by them they were like you
can do this do you want to try it and i
said yes then got up there and was
absolutely terrified but um that was one
of the things that we did it like two or
three times but it was for the fourth
film and
i will never be allowed to do a stunt
like that again like i've realized since
that that was very special circumstances
in this on that set and i i will never
be allowed to do something like that
again so yeah something like that that'd
be cool
you